[Musica]
grazie
l'uomo ferito a tutti è bellissimo
essere qui
innanzitutto ho imparato tantissime cose
dai precedenti speaker pazzesco dalla
genetica alle missioni spaziali ai
sistemi complessi di oggi con voi volevo
condividere una scintilla scintilla che
nota letto dentro di me ma anche una
scintilla che è nata da un sviluppatore
anonimo che si chiama satoshi nakamoto e
che proprio dieci anni fa ha innescato
questa scintilla che potrebbe
sconvolgere come una bomba nucleare
tutto il mondo della finanza per come lo
conosciamo fin ora è con voi parlerò di
l'innominabile quello che se fossimo in
una saga di harry potter sarebbe di 1 v
lord voldemort bitcoin picco in un mondo
al contrario e come alice nel paese
delle meraviglie scritto quello che
conoscete finora è stravolto e capovolto
e per entrare in questo mondo è
importante sfogliare piano piano
l'apparenza innanzitutto volevo iniziare
chi di voi conosce il bitcoin block jane
holl e cripto alzate le mani seconda
volta fatti fare questo sforzo
ok fantastico pochi scordatevi tutto
quello che avete letto sentito fonte di
asimmetria cognitiva o informativa di
coloro che l'hanno trasmesso vi faccio
un esempio sciocco
parliamo di pre nominabile ovviamente
non ha senso parliamo di bruxelles a
bruxelles ha questi poteri magici tipo
l'immutabilità si approccia nip coin ma
non la biopsia indie tiro è stata non
solo è possibile mutare quello che c'è
scritto dentro è stato fatto né
occasione della dow quindi
scordatevi unite con me in questo
viaggio stupendo
all'inizio spaventa ma andiamo in una
profondità incredibile profondità che
forse può essere interessante forse può
essere il nostro futuro
questa scintilla e me come a scattate
sono un avvocato un umanista mi hanno
sempre interessato i sistemi il
pagamento sempre trovati affascinanti un
incontro fortuito nel 2014 con un mio
carissimo amico più grossi esperti e
sistemi di pagamento mi fa simo ma tu ti
rendi conto il bitcoin io avevo letto
qualcosa lo guardi come questo che sta
dicendo questo è un giubbettino di che
si scambieranno al massimo quattro
oggetti di marvel
annuisco perché sai non devi sempre fare
la figura che le cose non le è proprio
capite e lascio andare
una settimana dopo mi chiama simoncelli
tappa a milano torna io non vivo più in
italia un po di anni si torna che c'è
fondamentalmente gli esperti più grandi
più importanti europei
e allora a quel punto dico forse mi sto
perdendo qualcosa
vado là mi metto a leggere il party
satoshi nakamoto che è anonimo e poi vi
spiegherò perché è importante essere
anonimi del 31 ottobre 2008 in cui lui
lancia due bombe pazzesche dice questo è
un puro sistema decentralizzato di
scambio di denaro elettronico online
senza l'intervento di istituzione
finanziaria completamente ri
centralizzato non c'è bisogno di terze
parti
valuto a leggere e capiscono
implicazione credo aver capito
l'imprecazione all'inizio va da questo
meetup o un altro incontro fortuito
fortunato con altri due personaggi
giacomo succo grossi visionari
fisico teorico e gabriele domeniche un
imprenditore profondo conoscitore questa
tecnologia il primo investitore in
italia in questa tecnologia e società
ovviamente essere e loro mi aiutano a
sfogliare a capire bene questo gol per
parte io cosa stiamo parlando
stiamo parlando di non soltanto il
denaro per internet
ma il denaro su un protocollo sul
network questo che significa viene meno
il concetto di stato meno il concetto e
società di banca centrale mittente viene
meno il concetto di censura viene meno
il concetto di autorizzazione viene il
concerto di vere versy bilità c'è una
orizzontalità tra produttore e
consumatore fucking via e chi riceve
tutto questo non può essere fermato non
può essere censurato in più b con
un'altra caratteristica che spaventa
moltissimo
qual è innanzitutto non bisogna chiedere
il permesso ma seconda cosa il tentativo
di trasformare il loro fisico ai tempi
di internet perché perché bitcoin a cosa
che rende qualcosa di valore un storo
valio o come lo chiamano la scuola
economica austriaca sun mani qualcosa
che sia raro e che sia difficile o così
o gustoso produrre l'oro che sempre il
bene rifugio ma anche bitcoin potranno
essere prodotti soltanto 21 milioni
nessuno cambierà questo l'emissione è
matematicamente stabilita dal protocollo
nessuno può cambiare quindi non è
soggetta a manipolazione di alcune
entità sui tassi di interesse
quindi noi inflazione deflazione
non a caso il bitcoin viene comprato in
maniera violenta nel momento in cui c'è
momento dell'iperinflazione in venezuela
quando c'è stato il crollo della moneta
turbati è stata un'impennata di questi
acquisti in turchia
l'argentina è comune così come le nelle
filippine
questo non lo vedete riflesso sul prezzo
della moneta per un semplice motivo
perché si compra peer to peer in maniera
completamente decentralizzata
quindi noi abbiamo da quinta rivoluzione
nel mondo del sistema bancario in cui
viene meno il concetto di stato in cui
vi è il concetto di controllo come
internet ha ridato la libertà di
espressione la libertà di parlare e
essere ascoltati senza confini senza in
teoria essere sottoposti a alcuna
censura
così il picco nella potenzialità di
ridarci la nostra libertà finanziaria
che forse è la più importante ma non
dobbiamo fare l'errore che abbiamo fatto
con internet perché in internet cosa è
successo a diventato uno strumento di
monitoraggio di massa di controllo di
massa e anche di lavaggio del cervello
ce lo dice snow the cell ha detto
wikileaks ce lo dice tutto quello che
succede in facebook google
eccetera eccetera chi allora abbiamo
fatto noi abbiamo messo subito torrent
un mezzo per poter filtrare qualsiasi
controllo
quello che vogliamo fare noi in bitcoin
quello che stiamo lavorando adesso che
sono i dieci anni in cui è venuta la
luce ma sono pochi anni
in cui si è capito la sua pericolosità
e come si è capita sapete come se capita
purtroppo wikileaks assange
assange era nell'ambasciata non potrà
ricevere più nessuna donazione due
senatori americani hanno bloccato
qualsiasi pagamento bonifico ha bloccato
tutti i circuiti di pagamento amex di
san masterclass non poteva più ricevere
donazioni che succede purtroppo qualcuno
ha avuto l'idea geniale perché ancora il
protocollo non era pronto di mettere
questo protocollo sotto riflettori
lui ha ricevuto denaro nella forma di
bitcoin l'anno scorso ha ringraziato i
due senatori perché la ricchezza della
fondazione dell'utile hicks è aumentata
del 50 mila per cento
questo purtroppo però dimostrato agli
stati che è un mezzo abbastanza
incensurabile cosa permette il fatto che
un quid non posso essere censurato
innanzitutto che sia completamente
centralizzato non puoi colpire nessuno
lo stesso attore del dl per pare anonimo
molti sviluppatori sono anonimi e quando
ai tantissimi noti come il caso napster
verso torrent per i giovani che
sicuramente sono in sale sanno che cosa
sto parlando
fa sì che se tu non puoi individuare o
comunque molto difficile perché al mondo
disperso
chi vuoi abbattere non lo puoi abbattere
questa la centralizzazione ma in più la
privacy la pravacy del mittente cioè e
anonimo chi invia e chi riceve come
l'indirizzo ip e in più la moneta non
deve essere avere traccia di tutti i
passaggi che sono sottostanti questo
ancora con bic ma non è possibile ex
auto anonimo è estremamente fungibile ma
la ricerca che stiamo portando avanti
soprattutto la scadenza di alcuni
brevetti
fanno sì che in un anno un anno e mezzo
questo sarà possibile metterlo in
pratica
quindi abbiamo un dna completamente
antagonista prima parlava di allineare
il genetica questo è un mostro un mostro
oppure un dio che ci permette di
liberarsi essere liberi che permette di
partecipare al sistema finanziario tutti
gli under bank che permette di poter
decidere proprio soldi di non ricevere
prelievi forzosi
basta ricordare italia e cipro che tutti
quei 10 che fanno parte le nostri soldi
che non sono più nostri vittorino essere
con tutte le responsabilità che abbiamo
nel nostro libero arbitrio non nel libro
abito che qualcun altro
dall'altra parte cosa abbiamo abbiamo il
sistema finanziario tradizionale
torniamo fuori dalla tana e satoshi come
cosa è il sistema tradizionale
sicuramente molto rassicurante noi
abbiamo la fiducia in queste valute
digitali per come sapete che euro
dollaro eccetera eccetera stampate
soltanto dal punto in cui per cento che
si chiamano tecnicamente fiat money
cos'è un fiat money è una moneta che non
ha una valuta non ha un valore
intrinseco e che qualche autorità
centrale la decreta avente valore legale
si prete dal 71 da quando nessuna moneta
più legata a loro il valore viene dato
dalla fiducia che non abbiamo una banca
centrale che non è diminuirà il suo
valore e che comunque avremo in cambio
un qualcosa
una fiducia che noi ci affidiamo noi
sappiamo che questo tipo di sistema
finanziario
per mission questo sistema finanziario
si può censurare questo sistema
finanziario può congelare i nostri fondi
questo sistema finanziario può fare
riserva frazionaria e che significa
questo perché si dovrebbe interessare il
prestito selvaggio dà luogo a bolle la
bolla subprime è un risultato ad un
prezzo selvaggio a quell'ora finito il
tempo che è voltato vantaggio sono di
molto attivi con il tempo mi hanno detto
che dovevo solamente rispettarlo che ha
portato vantaggi a poche banche
d'investimento e per il principio della
socializzazione delle perdite e della
privatizzazione degli utili ha portato
di grossi svantaggi a tutte le economie
e a ogni singola persona
due dna completamente diversi
sinceramente il primo è avveneristico
sembra impossibile però io gli darei un
occhio sembra che abbia molti più
vantaggi rispetto al secondo nel secondo
perdere sicuro
sicuramente il frutto del mio lavoro sì
lo posso spendere dove mi pare forse ma
il frutto del mio lavoro
oggi vale 10 domani vale 15
no scusate oggi vale 10 domani vale 5 e
poi dovrò pagare la retta dei miei
bambini loro dire ragazzi puntate sulla
borsa di studio dna completamente
diverso antagonista è nato per stare al
di fuori delle regole è nato per essere
un linguaggio di valore che è nato per
essere scisso dallo stato lo stato non
lo riconosce e quindi è molto provati lo
comanda
voi mi chiederete non lo comanda nessuno
ci sono trattori fondamentali che sono i
miners i nodi e developer's ognuno di
noi può essere un
e questo non deve lo personale capacità
è aperto e devono trovare un accordo su
qualsiasi possibile xvi tour per
sviluppo del protocollo
se non c'è accordo non semplicemente ha
quindi ci sono discussioni infinite dei
drammi degli interessi confliggenti
delle guerre delle accuse
andiamo avanti per mesi per anni ma
senza il consenso di ognuno perché non
si può imporre basato sull'etica non si
ottiene nulla il protocollo rimane tale
e quale c'è stata una grandissima prova
di forza
un anno fa da the manner dal 54 per
cento di potenza di calcolo e in una
sola persona che si chiama jean bull è
affatto una prova in forza uno strappo
ci ha provato per avere più soldi si è
innescata una guerra senza religione con
il suo 54 per cento della parte più
importante che la fotografia provo work
non è riuscito a implementare la sua
idea perchè non era etico perché non era
giusto quindi noi ci troviamo di fronte
a un progetto un progetto per fallibile
per effetto lindo ogni giorno che
guadagna è un giorno in più della sua
sopravvivenza e differita la sua
mortalità nel 2050 cosa può succedere
150 succede può succedere che muore
muore perché c'è uno stigma sociale
ancora il b con il denaro tel
classi schroth il denaro ad essiccare
del tar web non è vero tutte le sedi
collo sono anonimi transazioni sono ben
visibili e quando c'è qualcosa di poco
chiaro
quei soldi rimangono la il metodo più
efficace per commettere crimini sono i
contanti oil money and land ring fatto
dalle banche questo sono dei ricerche
scientifiche non sono le opinioni
ovviamente di un bitcoin maxima list
come può
ipotesi di mezzo
citando adam back uno dei padri di
questa tecnologia è frammentato express
dire il bie colf 21 milioni e miliardi
di persone specie gli under 20 sono
tantissimi credo che una nicchia
funzionerà secondo l'economia del
bitcoin vivrà secondo l'economia di
bitcoin altro scenario possibile quello
ottimista è un linguaggio di valore che
consisterà con altri linguaggi di valore
sicuramente noi abbiamo aperto una
voragine è possibile vivere senza il
controllo di autorità centrali e è
possibile vivere in maniera etica e 48
secondi che mi rimangono vi racconto una
cosa che nel mondo reale non potrebbe
mai accadere
tranne guerra su un cambiamento
contrapposizione con il più famose
vangelis andrea santona un polo su
twitter contro non le padri del bitcoin
che però una morsa malevola e a un certo
punto dice in maniera spregiativa giu
senatori vandalizzare è consumato i
bitcoin è adesso se povero fai schifo
l'altro i dice è vero ma credevo che
fosse importante per me comunicare al
mondo questo valore
lo sapete cosa è successo in 24 ore ha
ricevuto donazioni anonime per un
controvalore di 2 milioni
non aveva chiesto nulla la comunità
ritenuto che avesse dato valore grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]